foreign
thank you
foreign
thank you
foreign
all right
foreign
foreign
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
the United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude he is gone ladies and
gentlemen Alex Jones is now very very
upset with me look at that that is a
freaking Predator right there he thinks
he's smarter than you think he's better
than you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the new award because
Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone
dad is telling my children who not to be
it's me
what you asked for is now at the door
scratching so open the door and prepare
to meet your destiny
that is a freaking prefer director right
there
smarter than you and she's better than
you and he's gonna beat you
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too nonsense okay now
that we are up under our bodies regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it I want what eight or eleven
bucks
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
[Music]
if highway robbery is what you doing
mangoes
[Music]
well welcome everybody it is election
2022 and we are moments away moments
away from a debate between a completely
normal smart
moral as far as I know honest and
ethical person and his name is Mark
Kelly he's the incumbent Democratic
senator
and the complete and total magalunatic
named Blake Masters as well as quite
frankly a third guy named Mark Victor
who I never heard of until five minutes
ago and apparently as part of the debate
running as an independent
so that's what we've got going on now in
a normal country
if we had a country that was even
remotely normal
this race would be a blowout actually if
we had a country that was remotely
normal someone like Black Masters
wouldn't even have a chance
because nobody would vote for him even
in the primary
this is not a normal country
and uh look at the polling look at this
vile polling Masters versus Kelly
it's Kelly plus four
this should be a 40-point race
at least
it's insane that this is a race and so
if you live in Arizona you have the
choice between
um a well credentialed
Family Man former astronaut named Mark
Kelly who isn't going to do anything
extreme one way or the other and we'll
vote for you know most democratic
proposals
or a complete and total lunatic
complete and total lunatics so the
debate today I expect will be
extraordinarily interesting
um are these fake glasses
uh
uh fake in what sense like CGI no
they're they're very real
and I can't see a thing without them
it's bad actually it's really really bad
they're real and unfortunately in this
studio
sometimes look at that hold on where is
it
imagine if I did the entire thing like
this with the light reflecting that
would be really bad I'm like dark
Brandon uh hold on let's see here's
another one another light
there it is
hold on a second
see that
that's ugly we can't I don't want that
to happen so anyway I'll try to um
I'll try to keep that you know the
reason why people wondering people came
to me with tears in their eyes and they
said sir let me buy you some contact
lenses and then people argued about who
would buy me contact lenses I'm getting
up so early with the baby
that I'm just like done with the
contacts by this time of night that's
quite frankly what it is that's that's
really the uh that's really the the
situation okay so that's that let's
continue because we have so many
different things going on today to talk
about uh oh producer Pat sent me this I
heard of this and didn't see it this is
Linda Paulson running for the Utah
Senate in in District 12. I guess you
know state district she does a rap and
it's extremely cringy my suggestion
would be to get the kids out of the room
hey Utah District 12. listen up right
here there's a new name on the ballot
for the Senate this year my name is
Linda Paulson
Republican and awesome love God and
family and the Constitution I tried to
get another conservative to rent nobody
could do it so I'm getting it done I'm
pro-religious Freedom pro-life Pro
police the right to bear arms and the
right to free speak I want less
government control and regulation want
to stop and expose all political
corruption
morality accountability government
programs should lead to self-sufficiency
and support traditional family as the
fundamental unit of society but in
schools there pushing for new movies and
just to clarify as a female adult I know
what a woman is
[Music]
absolutely electric music there very
very exciting stuff
so that's something that exists and uh I
don't know that I can really say
too much more about it
uh Super Chat just came in
bronxbjorn says sir I think the glasses
improved your poll numbers by at least
40 you know guys if I ran against Thomas
Jefferson
Jesus and Muhammad I would win by 40
points is that incredible what I would
win I don't know and it's meaningless
but yeah uh how did your Yom Kippur fast
go it went well to very well I broke the
fast with beautiful matzo ball soup
um I had kugel
potato latkes
an absolutely perfect
um stuffed cabbage
and uh what else
did I do applesauce or sour cream on the
lot because I did applesauce but then I
did a Greek yogurt with the leftovers
and then what else did I have oh uh and
then a cheese blintz for dessert it was
it was actually really really good very
very good
Andrew says the Abbott Beto debate was
unwatchable what changes would you make
to improve these debates I would let the
candidates speak that would be the main
thing I would suggest for these debates
yeah that debate was an absolute and
total disaster humiliating humiliating
disaster all right let's look at a
couple other things someone uh not
someone
independent NN who is the author of a
number of different
songs and videos for the show we had a
new song The David packman uh sea shanty
song and I said somebody please make a
music video for it I present to you
David packman C Shanty music video
looking for a place to watch some news
where people don't yell while wearing
suits I know of a guy who fits that bill
of aggressive with political
[Music]
knowledge sign up for a membership now
for the bonus show that's pissed who's
the current president of the United
States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
foreign
I'd rather not answer that how's that
congregation
[Music]
this is me and my Aviary a couple years
ago they're all summer it's time to
pluck it
foreign
all right so there it is that's David
packman C Shanty uh music video version
which I think is really really good I
like that very very much uh folks people
are pouring in here and I want to make
sure I don't miss anybody thanks Tina
for the 20 Super Chat
Credo says your thoughts on the court of
appeals striking down Trump at every
turn in regards to the classified
documents now granting the doj expedited
appeal have not reviewed the expedited
appeal ruling yet we'll look at it in
time for tomorrow's podcast by the way
I almost never mentioned this we have an
audio podcast and I would love it if you
signed up uh just subscribe to it it's
free honestly I don't care if you prefer
to watch on YouTube Just Having people
subscribe to the audio podcast on
whatever platform you use whether it's
you know iTunes music or Stitcher
whatever
um it's really really a great thing we
have that Daily Audio podcast and it's a
beautiful beautiful thing
in 15 seconds can you ask me a question
sure Andrew what's your take on ravioli
for or against
um James says sir I'm coming to you with
tears in my eyes asking me to play
Random clips of trump flubbing his
speech despite his very powerful brain
yeah I have a couple new Trump elements
here further scream that his days are
numbers yeah
hold on I'm coming I've got that one
what else do I have here from Trump
people were starting to come but he's
going to represent you long and hard
yeah so those are my newest uh
newest um
Trump elements let me oh my goodness I
am missing so much I want to say thank
you to Davis Schultz for signing up at
joinpakman.com and becoming new member
number one this evening also a big thank
you to Jason sickmeyer for gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com and over
on Twitch the situation is
extraordinarily explosive I want to say
thank you to manje poutine
Breezy nug Wrangler gifted five putting
us at seven Gordon Z hall is eight
s Prez gifted 20 which is 28 our friend
Lars Baron Roth re-upping for month 29
that's 29 total and then tiger girl
makes it 30 30 plus two zero plus two is
two nothing to carry and then you've got
your three so that puts us at 32 out of
a hundred and that's like roughly a
third I can I can eyeball it by looking
at that 32 out of 100 is roughly a third
all right let's keep going because I
have so many other important things the
Pacman Finance YouTube channel is
blowing up if you were hoping to be one
of the first ten thousand
I offered you to be one of the first
1000 and many of you missed it and then
I offered you to be one of the first
five thousand to subscribe to Pacman
finance and many of you missed it and I
said guys 10 000 is coming quick this is
the fastest growing YouTube channel
we've ever had
and then that Milestone has now been
missed so there is really good stuff
on the finance channel it's not
political it's all buttoned up personal
finance stuff
um so take this opportunity get in on
the ground floor get in on the ground
floor is what I would say one other
thing I wanted to mention I have been
thinking that as a goof it would be
really interesting to get like a huge
billboard promoting the show I know that
there are some people like Tim Poole at
all who have
um
done that and it's like it's almost as
more interesting for the reactions and
as a goof than for the publicity because
quite frankly like I was looking up in
the New York area what can we do Staten
Island would be funny because Staten
Island's the most right wing of the
various boroughs
but you look at these it's like it's
really not for the publicity because
look the daily circulation it's 77 000.
like for a show like ours
70 7 000 anything isn't going to move
the needle unless it's 77 000 paid
subscribers but what I mean is from an
in from the standpoint of impressions
77 000 is not that much but if anybody
in the audience knows about buying
Billboards has a connection can get us
pricing like this for example
you can get a mobile billboard in New
Rochelle for three grand that seems like
a terrible deal I don't know that New
Rochelle is the place to be for us but
in any case I think this would be super
interesting and
um it might turn into a thing where
people will go and photograph themselves
with the billboard and maybe we'll get
trolling maybe we could you know
fundraise around it or something like
that so the point here is calling all
billboard experts I would love
um for you to get in touch if you can
facilitate or something like that and
also I would go with the conservative
area like the idea of New York City is
interesting because it's New York City
but I would I would do like a
conservative area they're probably way
cheaper
um and the the the lulls value is
probably similar so the Val yeah
um
so we'll look into that very strongly
Australian to US Dollar exchange rate is
negative so you were giving me money
yeah that's true if you super chat from
Australia you actually earn money it's
really crazy
and thanks to Marcus Bustos for signing
up at joinpakman.com your new member
number 33. all right I have so many
other things to get to that I don't want
to continue uh wasting time
here's something absolutely hilarious
I'm going to cover this on the podcast
tomorrow
as many of you no doubt know
um right now Herschel Walker is in the
middle of an abortion Scandal now why is
it a scandal well it's a scandal because
he's an incredible hypocrite and he says
oh abortion's murder never no exceptions
for anything I guess the exception is if
he accidentally gets a woman pregnant
and it would be inconvenient to have a
baby then all of a sudden he's for it
he's accused of having paid for an
abortion after
urging an ex-girlfriend to get one so
this is the best
somehow
he does a press conference Herschel
Walker can barely speak so who allowed
him to do this to the extent that his
advisors can actually influence him this
went so poorly
that I just can't even believe it take a
look at this
of your children
no to ask why why not uh why'd I need to
well because according to the article
one of the woman who says that you paid
for her to have an abortion the question
is have you called any of the mothers of
your children
also the mother of one of your children
it seems like that's that's an easy way
because of the article I have more kids
because of the article I had more kids
what does that mean
that'd be like if I were to say because
of a basketball card I had more kids
like what does that mean
I don't even understand what that means
because of the article I had more kids
that's why I reached out to you don't
want me because I said no and that's
what I mean when I said no I I said it's
not correct that's a lie and that's what
I mean that's a lie
let me go to her thank you said that if
this did happen there's nothing to be
ashamed of how do you think this morning
he did say that he said it he said it in
the morning yeah you know what I said I
was talking about something totally
different yeah he was literally asked
let's go to that clip uh here he is this
was this morning he did indeed say if he
did it there's nothing to be ashamed of
I'm saying I've been forgiven because of
all the things I did when I went to my
when uh the thing with my ex-wife and
all that and things I did I don't know
how many years ago that I wrote in my
book I said guys I wasn't perfect
I had my problem with mental health
and I was uh I've uh I've been I've I've
been I hate that I've been born again
but I have a new life and I've been
moving forward and and if that had
happened I would I would have said it
was nothing to be ashamed of if that had
happened I would have said it because
there's nothing to be ashamed of he did
say it
he did say it it's it's all completely
and totally Bonkers uh here's another
funny moment where I won't even explain
it let's just listen commercial
lieutenant governor Jeff Duncan went on
TV I think last night and had some very
critical words of Youth saying that the
Republican party was in disarray yeah I
think his directs both paraphrasing it
was the only reason he's the Republican
nominee is because he scored a lot of
touchdowns for the University of Georgia
now who was it you said where did that
Jeff Duncan oh what is he doing now
oh God wait who the lieutenant governor
said the following who said that oh
lieutenant governor Duncan what is he
doing now he's the lieutenant governor
like we've mentioned multiple times now
I don't know what is he doing now he's a
detailed work for who don't go on some
TV no no they only go on the TV and talk
a lot he's still no no they only go on
TV and talk a lot right now you know
people like that do I listen to you know
people told me I couldn't play football
so do you want me to listen to someone
like that I'm here to win this seat for
the Georgia people I mean it's I don't
know much about Jeff Duncan but I guess
it's probably true that uh uh Jeff
Duncan does not play football that's
probably true what's your reaction to
people so close to you your son a mother
of your someone who says it's you the
mother of your kids saying that you're
lying once you're actually people so
close to you saying don't trust you yeah
just like what I just said the Democrat
is desperate for this seat this season
his son Christian Walker is a right-wing
Maga influencer like yeah Democrats
really have it out for me right but your
son loves Trump what are you even
talking about they're they're very
desperate for this seat I love my family
I always love my family all right so
this was a really really really bad idea
okay here's the ashamed about thing all
right so we're going to move on to the
Kanye interview in a moment but how
wacky is that I mean you I don't know
you know how much he talked to the
advisors before making the decision to
do that but that was a really really
really bad press conference
um and on tomorrow's podcast I'll have a
more more in-depth breakdown a few other
super chats coming in Paco says love
your streams you got me into keeping a
closer eye on politics and will always
appreciate you for it stay safe thank
you I really appreciate that
Bronx says the Jesus reverse Uno but I'm
Christian nonsense right
absolutely
thanks to pinky grad woman Sling Blade
and snortzie for the twitch Prime
subscriptions I've got one other song
new song to play for you this is from I
I believe the correct pronunciation is
Kishore this is a new song I receive
check this out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ty song we've ever had and we've had a
lot of high quality songs
[Music]
because by these are clips from when oan
anchor Alison Steinberg came after me
[Music]
two two
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
Obama
[Music]
guys there is no video people are like I
can't see the video there is no video
this is just a song it's audio
all right then it goes on
okay so you get it anyway so that's
another possibility folks could uh if
you want to make a video out of it just
email info davidpackman.com ask for the
uh ask for the audio file Wesley with a
50 super chats has been watching for
Years glad I can finally help out Slava
ukraini absolutely
absolutely all right should we look at
the Kanye interview it's pretty
despicable Kanye West now apparently an
all lives matter Advocate appeared with
um and a white lives matter Advocate
appeared with Tucker Carlson just the
perfect combination for the people even
if you don't believe in God God believes
in you right so you guys know that
that's actually that's pretty deep
that's pretty deep made reference to the
White lives matter t-shirt which you
brought out at Paris Fashion Week why
did you do that and what did it mean
you know
I did I do certain things from a feeling
I like I just I just channeled the
energy it just feels right it's
using
a gut instinct a connection with God
and God told him to wear a white lives
matter shirt in Paris that's that's
interesting God's got quite a quite a
sense of humor huh
just Brilliance you know like it's if
you ask like Tonya Harding how
she did the the triple flip or the
triple spin what about you asked Tonya
Harding how she came up with having
Nancy Kerrigan uh uh Nancy herrigan's
leg broken or whatever it was that's a
better question she was in so much
practice that when it was time for her
to escape in a in a competitive format
it just happened like it happened
outside of practice that happened in the
real format imagine thinking this makes
sense and imagine being Tucker Carlson
and just like nodding along to this it's
clearly someone who has very limited
connection to reality and that's what
hap that's what's happening is God is
like preparing us for the real for the
real battles and we are we are in a
battle with the media like the majority
of the media has a a Godless agenda and
this guy is completely out of it I mean
this this probably is better for a
psychiatric situation but he's hitting a
lot of points that are super useful
politically for Tucker that's it's
almost Tucker's almost like taking
advantage of him in a way folks are
networking this whole like oh yeah he's
crazy and all these things they don't
work because the media has you know
they've also
watch travesties happen just even
specifically to me and just watch it and
act like it wasn't happening this might
be too much even for Tucker and they
stay quiet about it
um what are they I want to answer the
the white I feel like someone caught
what I was saying the comparison of
Tonya Harding about the the white lives
matter you know my dad is a educated
uh ex-black Panther
and he put a text to me today he said
White lives matter
and I said I thought the shirt was
a funny shirt I thought the idea of me
wearing it was funny and I said that
what do you think it was funny he said
just
just a black man stating the obvious
yeah wow that's deep this is Tucker's
wow that's deep face isn't that great
guys Tucker thinks it's very very deep
let's look at um let's look at another
clip here
um how when did you start to feel this
way when did you start to realize this
I I really felt like I think I started
to really feel this need to express
myself on another level when Trump was
running for office and I liked him and
every single person in Hollywood from my
ex-wife to my
mother-in-law to my manager at that time
to you know my my so-called friends
slash handlers around me told me like if
I said that I like Trump that my career
would be over that my life would be over
uh they said stuff like people get
killed for wearing a hat like that they
threatened my life they put my life they
basically said that I would be killed
uh for
uh wearing the Hat I had a uh someone
called me last night and said anybody
wearing a white lives matter shirt is
going to be green lit and that means
that they're going to beat them up if
they wear it and I'm like you know okay
green like me then right
wow
pretty powerful declarations huh
uh yeah so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
that's the obvious thing yeah there it
is yeah
they do
White lives matter yeah they do
um I think I have like one more now this
is something else
so that's pretty weaponized stuff that's
pretty weaponized stuff
um
jeez
man I don't even really know what to say
it's it's all Bonkers it's all bonkers
uh anybody have any opinion on that I
mean I don't even really know
what to say but
it's all sad it's just like a mixture of
confusion and mental illness and
opportunism and reactionary thinking and
um
yeah I don't know I really don't I
missed the old Kanye yeah there you go
that's that's a fair fair position
chitty says sir I had kbbq I guess that
means Korean barbecue in Helsinki
yesterday I heard some Finns
regurgitating the same transphobic
talking points touted by the American
right horrifying that's that's sad
that's very sad folks we are two minutes
away from the debate in the U.S Senate
race between incumbent Democrat Mark
Kelly Maga endorsed Republican candidate
Blake Masters and an independent
candidate named Mark Victor who to be
totally Frank I have never heard of I
think that this is going to be an
interesting debate because Masters is
completely out of his mind and Mark
Kelly is like so normal and buttoned up
so I'm so glad that you're joining me I
would love for you to show your support
of our ongoing 2022 debate coverage we
have more than a dozen other debates
scheduled for the remainder of the
election season to cover live live live
including some nights with multiple
debates back to back which I might do or
I might not I would love for you to show
your support for that and for my glasses
by signing up at joinpakman.com we have
an we have a humiliatingly modest goal
of a hundred subscribers today we're
already at 36 which is 36 of the way
there by my according to my TI-83
calculator and you can use the coupon
code indict
to save a humiliating amount off of the
membership I don't even want to tell you
what the discount is because it's too
embarrassing to say out loud needless to
say I will do my best to thank every
single person who grabs one of those
memberships before or after the debate
which is scheduled to start any moment I
also want to say thank you to pow owl
High goal Mrs Coyne and JP the Beast for
twitch Prime subscriptions and S press
just gifted six of them which puts us at
46.46 we are I believe on track to get
to a fantastic number let's see if I can
squeeze in one more clip here before the
debate starts it's it's a steady
onslaught of onslaught on [ __ ] oh my God
what is he talking about it's it's a
steady onslaught of Onslow God Rand Paul
Jumping the Shark propaganda just keep
getting vaccinated so people don't
believe them anymore because according
to Dr fauci you might need 10 vaccines
100 vaccines there's no limit to these
people because they're not willing to
look at the science
all right an onslaught jeez edgy
material from Rand Paul I'm sort of
shocked to hear that that's uh
the direction he's going with his uh
with his rhetoric Masters if I win it's
legit if Kelly wins its fraud
yeah I almost do think I should have
some backup stream just in case this
thing doesn't go live uh Mark Kelly does
it will help determine which party will
control there it is a senate our debate
Rules tonight are that each candidate
will get 90 seconds to answer a question
with 45 second rebuttal periods each
candidate also gets a little better
opening and closing statement with
closing statements going in reverse
order of the opening remarks now fourth
tonight's debate in alphabetical order
we welcome Democratic incumbent Senator
Mark Kelly a retired astronaut with NASA
he also served in the U.S Navy
Republican Blake Masters an attorney
businessman and a member of the Trump
2016 transition team and libertarian
Mark Victor an attorney who served in
the U.S Marine Corps there he is let's
get things started with opening
statements and we begin with Blake
Masters
hi I'm Blake Masters I'm running to be
your next Senator because our current
Senator Mark Kelly has messed everything
up our border is in chaos we've got
drugs and illegal aliens just pouring in
oh crime is up the cost of groceries
actually the cost of everything you need
to live keeps going up that's Kelly's
Fault by the way it wasn't like this two
years ago
what changed well Joe Biden took over
and in Washington Mark Kelly backs Joe
Biden every single time without thinking
twice without thinking of Arizona you
know it's not what he said he'd do two
years ago Mark Kelly stood right there
and he promised to be independent
but he broke that promise my wife
Catherine and I grew up right here in
Arizona we're raising our three little
boys here now and we're sick of seeing
Arizona families suffer just because
Mark Kelly wants to fit in in DC
send me to the U.S Senate and I will put
Arizona families first thank you super
thank you very much and now we turn to
Mark Victor super creepy Live and Let
Live that's my position on every issue
live your life however you choose just
let other people do the same thing my
name is Mark J Victor and if you're
tired of the same old politics I'm your
guy I'm a proud Marine Corps combat
veteran and for the last 28 years I've
been thinking outside the box as a
criminal defense attorney but the most
important thing I've done was found the
Live and Let Live Global Peace Movement
we got two rules don't infringe on
anybody's freedoms and let's just
inspire people to be good humans the
Republicans and the Democrats together
both are responsible for 31 trillion
dollars in debt and the highest
inflation we've seen in 40 years
unnecessary Wars a mismanaged pandemic
and a tribalism that is tearing us apart
one of them kisses Biden's ring the
other kiss is Trump's ring I don't kiss
anybody's ring unlike my opponents I am
not here to impose my personal views on
anyone I'd be honored to tell you about
my plan to achieve freedom and peace for
everyone thank you thank you very much
and for our last opening statement we
hear from markelli Big enter Ted thank
you uh Blake and Mark good to meet you
both you know growing up we didn't have
a lot of money my parents were both cops
and they taught me about public service
I spent 10 years in the united I spent
25 years in the United States Navy as a
combat pilot and as an astronaut two
years ago you sent me to the United
States Senate to cut through the red
tape and get things done for Arizona now
we have more work to do families are
struggling and often can't afford gas or
prescription medication so I worked with
Republicans
to bring manufacturing back to America
to cut costs and when Democrats are
wrong like on the border I call them out
on it because I'm always going to stick
up for Arizona
flake Master is my opponent on the other
hand has some beliefs that are just
dangerous for arizonans
he celebrated when Arizona enacted a
national enacted an abortion ban
and he wants to privatize your Social
Security sending your savings to Wall
Street so Ted this is an important
conversation all right gentlemen thank
you very much let's get things started
Senator we'll start with you inflation
is at generational highs uh could be
going even higher considering opec's
actions here this week regarding the his
master seven feet production why our
consumer prices so high what have you
done to address this issue yeah first of
all Ted let me start by saying as a kid
you know I remember my mom sitting at
the kitchen table you know with all the
bills spread out with one of those giant
calculators trying to figure out you
know what bill is she going to pay and
it was really challenging for her in
that period of time you know she could
only put about two dollars a gas in the
car you know at the time so I I know
what people are going through and I know
it's hard that's why I've worked to cut
costs hey when the when the president
when the Biden Administration refused to
increase oil and gas production I told
him he was wrong
and when prescription drugs are just
skyrocketed and seniors can't afford it
guys I I like Kelly he's not seeming
ready this is very shaky Blake Masters I
mean the issue we have here is that this
issue affects seniors more than anybody
else seniors that are on a fixed income
and my opponent
you know he wants to privatize Social
Security he said probably the question
was why are prices so high ending
your earnings to Wall Street I met this
uh older gentleman in Parker not too
long ago and he came up to me and he
said he said hey
please do not take away my Social
Security I don't know what I will do
forever long I'm in the United States
Senate I'm going to protect your Social
Security and Medicare because the
question was inflation to cut the knot
and privatize your Social Security
sending your hard-earned dollars to Wall
Street plague Masters 90 seconds we're
talking inflation here why is inflation
why are consumer prices so high and what
would you do about it let's be clear the
greatest threat to seniors retirement
today is the massive crushing inflation
that Joe Biden and Mark Kelly caused and
that's their fault they caused it
two years ago inflation was one and a
half percent now in the greater Phoenix
Metro area we are suffering from
literally the worst inflation in the
nation at 13 percent
Joe Biden's policies caused this and
those are policies that Mark Kelly in
Washington has supported everything
that's also completely untrue first they
declared war on oil and gas what were
what they think was going to happen when
you declare war on oil and gas in a
country that is still mostly powered by
oil and gas you think that's going to
send the price of energy to the Moon
well yeah I did they took gas from two
dollars to six dollars now they want a
prize because it's back in the five
dollars oh God no when you make energy
too expensive well everything is a gas
like 350 right now for to move you make
energy expensive you get some inflation
that was the left hook well the
Democrats weren't done then they decided
to print six trillion dollars they print
and spent six trillion dollars too
quickly printed the normal person
understands the PHD economists don't
apparently Senators don't but when you
print a trillion dollars that makes
every dollar in your wallet worth less
and less it sends prices at the
supermarket skyrocketing so no they
caused this crushing inflation and it is
ruining people's lives I had parents
come up to me two weeks ago to campaign
event they said here's in there you
don't eat breakfast anymore we drink
coffee we drink coffee so that we can
afford to feed our kids breakfast and
that's on you sir this is the Joe Biden
Mark Kelly economy I will put a stop to
Joe Biden's crazy spending he'll end it
right away after 90 seconds inflation
what's going on the people are hurting
right now inflation hurts the poor the
worst it's a tax on everything why is
this happening it's happening because of
both the Republicans and the Democrats
it's their foolish economic policies
look don't confuse money with wealth
they're not the same thing wealth that's
what's produced and what's consumed
Printing and distributing money doesn't
make us richer
doubling the money supply doesn't make
us twice as Rich printing money results
in more dollars to buy the same amount
of goods and that's what raises prices
both the Republicans and the Democrats
both of them have been recklessly
printing money it's not just this
Administration it's Bush it's Obama it's
Trump it's Biden they have all increased
spending they have all increased the
debt the Republicans just had control of
everything they increased spending they
increase the debt this has been
exacerbated by the way by forced
business closings during covet these are
probably unconstitutional but they
messed up our supply chain and it
contracted the number of goods when you
print more money and throw it in the
economy and you reduce the supply of
goods what you get is out of control
inflation and no you can't just pass
more spending and call it the inflation
reduction act and think you are going to
fix inflation you know what fixes this
free markets that's what raises
standards of living we need to cut taxes
we need to cut spending we need to cut
regulation we are stealing from future
Generations it's obscene it's immoral
and it needs to stop all right Mark
thank you very much so Mark Kelly seems
unprepared and shaky Blake Masters is a
lunatic and looks eight feet tall on the
stage and the libertarian guy seems like
a nice guy he'll be lucky to get one
percent of the vote so kind of a
non-factor covet 19. schools had a
shutdown businesses shut down across
Arizona we have half a million small
businesses you know sometimes the
federal government has to step in to
save small business
you know they have to step in to protect
livelihoods you know I my office uh
folks that work for me you know were
very active in helping small businesses
like Tres Leches Cafe in Phoenix stay
open
in Tucson
um we've got to get our debt and deficit
under control that's why in the
inflation inflation reduction act
reduces the deficit by hundreds of
billions of dollars at the same time I
was able to stand up to Big Pharma and
cut the prescription drug costs for
seniors capping it at two thousand
dollars a year spread out over the Year
this is something my opponent Blake
Masters has opposed
seniors are struggling
Social Security and prescription drugs
hits them harder than anybody else and
my opponent Blake Masters wants to
privatize their social security okay
sending that money to what my opponent
is absolutely enormous do you see the
size of this guy did we not need money
to be printed considering the coveted
pandemic that we were dealing with
that's what I'm hearing here Joe Biden
is spending like a drunken sailor and at
every single opportunity Mark Kelly just
says yes he can't say no to Chuck
Schumer he can't say no to Joe Biden at
least Senator Cinema stopped build back
better my gosh you were ready to vote
for that that would have just ruined our
economy even worse is Blake Masters
Canadian does anybody know mad at her
for that but hey isn't it interesting
that you had to wonder which way she was
going to vote you never have to wonder
which way Senator Kelly is going to vote
because any spending bill that Biden
puts in front of him he will sign so
yeah we got the inflation reduction act
and Mark Kelly was the deciding vote he
hired 87 000 new IRS agents Mark Kelly
voted to send stimulus checks to illegal
aliens he voted to send stimulus checks
to get this violent felons sitting in
jail is that a good use of taxpayer
money I don't think so think about that
the next time you go to the grocery
store and you can't afford to buy steak
or eggs let me get a quickly responsive
yeah yeah that that that's not true
which part well and the the well a lot
of it but the IRS part you know a lot of
it we need folks in government to go
after big businesses and the wealthiest
Americans who try to cheat on their
taxes that have armies of accountants
and lawyers
you know that's the intention you know
here because if we can't collect taxes
from the wealthiest Americans and the
largest corporations that are cheating
on their taxes you know who pays
middle class Americans himself he wants
87 000 IRS you're going to get a second
hold on so relax so you know what what
he is proposing is a system
that you know the little guy has to pay
more middle class Americans and working
class Americans we need to make sure
that big business and it's it's pretty
obvious when you look at the background
of each of us you know with regards to
like you know things like you know
ethics or form and corporate Pac money
I've never taken a dollar of corporate
Pac money my entire time in the last
campaign and I'll stick up for the
little guy because I am the little guy
look at the size of this guy next to me
hanging up for Arizona we need to stop
you right there all right uh again uh
response 45 yes you do the people of
Arizona know that those 87 000 IRS
agents that you're sicking on them
they're not just going after
billionaires live they're not just going
after big business they're going to be
auditing you they're going to be
auditing your small businesses this time
next year Senator Kelly voted for 87 000
new IRS agents on the inflation
reduction act but to do that first he
had to reject there was an amendment he
rejected hiring 18 55 000 of the 87 are
just to replace retiring people over the
next 10 years this a very small increase
to the size of the IRS and needed by the
way to audit those that are taking
advantage and not paying their fair
share priorities are Mark Kelly left our
Southern border wide open voted for all
the trillions in spending that caused
this massive inflation and he thinks the
fix is 87 000 new IRS agents something
tells me that's not going to work I want
to get Mark in here for a second I want
to get back to you thank you Ted you
know I want to speak up on behalf of the
drunken sailor because drunken Sailors
there's a limit to how much money a
drunken sailor can spend that isn't the
problem here the problem here is we
don't have sound money anymore in our
country that's the reason these guys are
bickering about spending more and more
and more money because there is no limit
to how much our government can continue
to print and spend we need to get back
to sound money again so the government
can't continue to have no limit on their
credit card that's the problem with our
economy there are always things to spend
more money on there will be a
never-ending list do we want to get a
control on our economy we need to get
back to a free market in sound money
okay uh Marco back the idea of IRS
agents over border agents
well you know I've spent a lot of time
in our Southern border and let me just
say it's a mess it's a chaos it's crisis
after crisis
I worked in in Washington to bring more
border patrol agents to the State of
Arizona a billion dollars for Staffing
and security security and monitoring
systems
um so this this premise that he's taken
voting against border patrol agents I've
worked hard to make sure we have the
money so we have more border patrol
Patrol agents on the ground and that's
what we have today
respond please okay did you or did you
not vote to reject
18 000 more border patrol agents in the
inflation reduction act passage Senator
you know we we there it is right there
there are votes that happen in DC that
have nothing to do with border patrol
agents and it might have the title on it
and nothing happens right so what I have
done is I got a billion dollars more for
border patrol agents for Staffing
you know for the Technical Systems to
monitor the border and where they make
sense to to build more border barriers
at the southern border are you sure
that's my that that's my record which is
I've been strong I think what you need
to say on something like that is there
are all sorts of border patrol
Provisions squeezed into unrelated bills
by your party
I voted on this bill and yeah something
like that that would create a bigger
crisis you know I told him he was wrong
so I pushed back on this Administration
multiple times and I've got more money
on the ground to increase border patrol
Staffing technology and where it makes
sense to build more barriers it sounds
like he says you're cherry picking here
he voted against hiring 18 000 more
border patrol agents and then said yes
to 87 000 new IRS agents I'm sure we're
going to talk more about the Border I
just want to ask one question sir have
you done everything in your power to
secure our Southern border
I've been focused on the border since
day one on this job I'm down there all
the time I was on the phone this week
just you know with mayor Nichols Sheriff
Daniels of Cochise County talking about
what more we need for border patrol and
immigration that my friends called The
Invasion we're we're working to raise
border patrol pay by 18 18 I've got
legislation to do that I've been focused
on the border since day one
okay you know with no great effects
because we have a wide open Southern
border so if that's the best you can do
that's not directly requested Let's get
someone in the seat right who will
actually secure our border Washington DC
has failed on this issue a border
security and immigration for decades
and it's been crisis after crisis I've
been focused on this since day one you
know and I bought I brought more
resources here to the State of Arizona
to deal with this issue let's let's
continue the focus on immigration we'll
go 90 seconds here uh Blake we'll start
with you
um
immigration reform uh I hear border
security mentioned a lot you have
mentioned border security you want to
secure the Border how would you know
when the border is secure how do we know
when the border is secure well call me
old-fashioned but I think the correct
amount of illegal immigration is zero
that's what federal law says remember
you could get rid of all border patrol
and then you could say we're not
catching anybody so it must be solved
this is very dumb they've given it up to
the Mexican drug cartels we had
operational control two years ago and
now it's just a complete disaster they
incentivize people to break the law
illegal aliens when they come here
they're supposed to be caught and
deported back to their home country or
back to some other country that wants
them but no Joe Biden and Mark Kelly
they laid out the welcome mat this is
the greatest country in the history of
the world if you invite everybody to
come here you'll create a crisis and so
5 million illegals literally 5 million
have come here in the last 22 months Joe
Biden and Mark Kelly have welcomed them
when these people cross they know not
only will they not be deported but
they're given envelopes with cash plane
tickets here's a hotel room in
Scottsdale
we treat these people better than we
treat our own U.S military service
members I find that shameful 300 000
come through every month it's a
humanitarian disaster the women and
children are raped the men are
indentured servants sold into some kind
of slavery and it's not just the people
it's the drugs the fentanyl that's
coming through
it's killing kids we're losing 2 000
arizonans every year to fentanyl the
stuff is poison it's coming right there
up through the southern border and Mark
Kelly and Joe Biden have not done a
single thing to stop it it is Carnage
and so I think we should secure the
border that means a wall it means
doubling the size of border patrol and
it means let's get back to deporting
people who try to break into our country
something that Mark Kelly routinely
votes against we'll get to Mark Kelly in
a second here but Mark Victor as far as
immigration reforms the wall worked so
well why would you need to double border
patrol if you do the wall I don't get
that keep talking about this same
problem Administration after
Administration after Administration
they're bickering about securing the
border and spending money but nobody
ever gets it done we need to get it done
I'm in favor of a comprehensive overhaul
of the entire immigration policy it
doesn't have to be very confusing we had
a great immigration policy in this
country in the late 1800s early 1900 in
fact we didn't even have a term illegal
immigration there was just immigration
it wasn't a big deal we welcomed
immigrants to America most of the people
who come to America and I've been
representing many of them over the last
28 years the vast majority of them are
great people they come here to work to
pursue the American dream
but they should get nothing when they
come here besides the right to
peacefully pursue their happiness nobody
has a right to live at the expense of
another person they should get no
welfare or social programs at all but we
do need to immediately secure the Border
nobody has a right to aggress against
anybody else whether they're inside or
outside the Border let's try to keep the
bad guys out we should streamline the
Asylum process it's ridiculous that it
takes so long to get a reasonably simple
hearing done I am very pro-immigration
it's good for America it helps our
economy we've got demographic issues as
well we need more younger workers can
you imagine our situation we've got a
huge labor shortage right now we got
lots of immigrants who want to work we
can't get a Visa program so they can
actually work let's get them to work
this is why Sheriff Hathaway in Santa
Cruz County endorsed me because I've got
a plan there is no oh perfect solution
here but we need a path to citizenship
as well okay I do not want to tear
families apart and we're here in working
in our law-abiding we should not be
deporting that is time uh 90 seconds
Mark Kelly immigration Wow have you done
enough as far as immigration concerns in
Arizona in the country you know when I
got to uh Washington DC one of the first
things I realized was that Democrats
don't understand this issue oh God and
Republicans just want to talk about it
and complain about it but actually not
do anything about it they just want to
politicize that we heard this tonight
for my opponent Blake Masters you know
he thinks he knows better than everyone
about everything
when it comes to border security you
know I've been focused on this and on
immigration yes we need comprehensive
immigration reform
we have ten tens of thousands tens of
thousands of dreamers here in the state
of Arizona
that are as American as my own two kids
I've got one daughter lives in Tucson my
granddaughter lives in Tucson I think of
dreamers
no different
you know my opponent Blake Masters on
the other hand he said he would never
offer citizenship to dreamers I think
it's mean and it's fundamentally
un-American we need comprehensive
immigration reform in a lot of different
ways I talk to Farmers and ranchers all
the time can't get the workforce they
need under the existing Visa programs
and they're really struggling I mean you
look at Yuma and the food supply issues
we have down there and the workforce
issues of legal immigration legal
immigrants coming across the border to
work here in the state of Arizona adding
so much to our economy but this issue
gets politicized over and over again
from people like my opponent Blake
Masters politicizing the issue not
understanding the issue respond please I
understand it very well I understand
that Mark Kelly supports open borders
and that's why we have them he's the
50th vote in the U.S Senate Joe Biden
needed his vote Mark Kelly a year ago
could have dug his heels in and said Mr
President I'm not supporting a single
thing not a single spending Bill not a
single piece of your agenda
and less than until we get border
security Biden would have had to secure
the Border Mark Kelly if he's if this is
the result of Senator Kelly being
focused on the border my gosh he's the
most ineffective and worst senator of
all time the borders wide open people
are walking through by the hundreds of
thousands you know if the Mexican drug
cartels if these terrorist narcos if
they could vote in this election every
single one of them would vote for
Senator Kelly because they get what they
want from him which is a complete wide
open border it's complete free reign and
again the fentanyl is killing our
children he's not doing a gosh darn
thing to stop it responsibly so the
fentanyl is out of control and it's
heartbreaking and I've spent a lot of
time down there on like Nogales and Yuma
and Douglas uh the head of CBP is Lupe
Ramirez and we've talked extensively
about this and he showed you know he's
we've talked about how this gets
smuggled through the ports of Entry
really early in my term in the Senate so
you know what I did went back to
Washington and I got the money
appropriated to rebuild our ports of
Entry you know why because right now if
you go down there it's 12 Lanes in
Nogales as an example only one of those
Lanes has the technology the X-ray
machine that can detect the fentanyl
when we rebuild these ports of Entry
because of the work I've done in the
United States Senate and getting this
money to Arizona every single one of
those Lanes will have the technology wow
but the only way you can do this is
through bipartisanship it's working
together working across the aisle to get
things done like John McCain did you
know my opponent Blake Masters he
doesn't want to work with anybody he
doesn't want to work with Republicans
you know he calls Democrats Psychopaths
and that they're evil that's not been
the spirit of how Arizona senators work
to the benefit of our state and our time
on that but I need a response from you
on the idea of working with Democrats on
cooperating across the aisle you might
be able to work with Democrats like
Cinema Democrats like Joe manchin you
can't work with Democrats Like Bernie
Sanders
Chuck Schumer Mark Kelly no there's
something very wrong with people who
don't want to enforce federal law who
don't believe in borders apparently they
don't believe in our national
sovereignty because they've turned over
the entire border Zone to Mexican drug
cartels and it is killing people it is
killing arizonans it's ruining our state
it's ruining our country he's not doing
a darn thing to stop it and the border
patrol understands this go ask a border
patrol agent what they think of Mark
Kelly ninety percent of them will tell
you they're disgusted by what he's
failed to do that's why the national
border patrol Council endorsed me the
Arizona Police Association endorsed me
it's time to get back to Law and Order
let's just even try it'd be bad enough
if they were trying to enforce federal
law and failing but they've just
surrendered they've thrown their hands
up and thrown our Southern border wide
open it's killing people I'm sick of it
45 seconds Mark Victor is is the Border
open right now and has it been turned
over to cartels of course the border is
open right now and people can come
through there's no question about that
but the answer here is we can walk into
this is so crazy it's like listen my
opponent Blake Masters doesn't actually
believe in democracy when his guy loses
and said abortion was a Satanic ritual
that people on the left do he is out of
his mind from them we are a nation of
immigrants we need we have a demographic
problem right now we need more younger
workers and also just a quick point on
civility we need to get back to civility
we shouldn't be calling each other names
and and arguing across the I agree with
what Senator Kelly said here we need to
work together people who disagree still
can be agreeable let's sit down and have
an exchange of ideas and speak like
gentlemen rather than arguing and
calling each other names like kids in a
sandbox all right uh I want to move to
abortion uh Senator Kelly will start
with you here we go would you codify Roe
v Wade course let me be perfectly clear
Arizona women have totally lost the
right to make a decision about abortion
it's devastating
it's wrong
it's exactly what my opponent Blake
Masters wants true Blake Masters
has called abortion demonic there it is
religious sacrifice he's even said that
he wants to
punish the doctors
he wants a National Abortion ban
that's so strict that even in the case
when a woman is raped she will not have
the option to make this decision right
now in a second he's going to tell you
that this isn't true
but folks this is true
these are his words
he has supported State and National
Abortion bans
that will deny the right for a woman to
make this decision by themselves all
right here we go that's what it's about
for Blake
I made
he's only saying this now and he's
probably going to tell you something
totally different and it's only because
he's trying to win an election
but that's what it's about for him you
know he thinks
that he should make these decisions for
you
he thinks he gets to make these choices
instead of you
Black Masters 90 seconds here regarding
a federal ban on abortion codifying Roe
v Wade where do you stand
I'm pro-life and that means I believe in
limits now I support exceptions because
I don't believe in being extreme on this
issue Senator Mark Kelly is the abortion
radical Senator Kelly in Washington he
voted you know actually he sponsored he
didn't just vote for it he sponsored a
bill
that would have mandated legal abortion
Nationwide get this up until the moment
of birth
man take a second to think about how
truly radical that is Mark Kelly says
any abortion is okay for any reason
all the way up until the moment so the
baby is due to be bored he wasn't the
only radical who voted for that bill he
was joined by Elizabeth Warren by Bernie
Sanders AOC voted for this in the house
and the only countries in the whole
world that support Senator Kelly's
preferred No Limits extreme abortion
policy or China and North Korea so no
I'm pro-life I believe in limits I think
we should be more like I don't know how
about every other civilized country in
the world just last year Arizona passed
a law that limits abortions after 15
weeks
I support that law that's where
arizonans find a reasonable place to
draw the line I support limits at the
federal level too Senator Lindsey Graham
has proposed a 15-week bill
with the common exceptions and I support
that I believe in limits Mark Kelly
believes in No Limits at all I
understand why he wants to lie about my
position because his own which is on the
record he sponsored that legislation up
until birth that is so truly radical
eighty percent of arizonans are
disgusted by that so I'm going to
represent the vast majority of arizonans
on this issue he's proven that he can't
need a response it's nonsense and what
he's saying is absolutely not true I've
always been clear on this that I support
the restrictions and the protections
that were allowed under Roe v Wade and
abortion only happens you know very late
in pregnancy when there are serious
issues
and folks it's heartbreaking when this
happens and often the child is wanted
but my opponent
remember what he has said I mean he
supports a National Abortion ban I just
told you I criminalize this that you're
going to get your chance
that criminalizes this decision he has
said and this isn't like years ago he
said very recently that he wants to
punish the doctors he's called abortion
demonic
a religious sacrifice I don't even know
what that means folks but what I'm doing
is I am protecting the constitutional
rights that you have lost I don't even
know is that rhetoric like this but real
quickly um do you where do you draw the
line on late term abortions well under
Roe v Wade
there were protections and there were
restrictions that were allowed under
that law
and late term abortion in this country
only happens when there is a serious
problem and you know that's what I
support and what he says about the
legislation that I voted on is just not
true and it's nonsense and he should go
back and take a look and read this I
mean he you know he's a lawyer this is
legislation he can go take a look at it
Blake you have said that you once
espouse a federal personhood law uh you
is this is a quote from you
unqualifiedly pro-life from conception
and that um
there has been it has been noticed that
some of these more strident uh positions
were taken off of your website so let's
say that you scrub them from your
website what's going on with that I
encourage people to go read my website
now it is still the most pro-life most
detailed read it now without all the
crazy [ __ ] what I'm pro-life I'm proud
to be pro-life I will never run from
that
I'm pro-life is a matter of conscience I
just told you what I believe the law
should be right in Arizona as a voter I
support the 15-week law with all the
exceptions I believe in federal limits I
believe at a certain point everybody of
good conscience knows
at five months six months my gosh seven
months that is a baby and we shouldn't
be killing babies for no reason when
they can survive outside the womb and
that's not what his legislation did they
said they were trying to codify Route no
it was so much more extreme than that
they wanted to impose legal abortion
Nationwide
up until the moment of birth and I just
that is way too radical that's not what
arizonans want Common Sense limits
Arizona has said 15 weeks make sense I
think that makes sense and before we get
to Mark Victor real quickly have you
always supported the 15-week limit
well Arizona just passed the law last
year and Senator Graham just introduced
the bill last month right but the
question is have you always supported
the bill nine months ago it was just
introduced not the bill it's the limit
did you have you always supported that
limit
that kind of limit I believe Arizona's
got the right to make its laws that's
the whole point of reversing Roe versus
Wade and I believe in a federal backstop
I think at the federal level we should
not be allowing late terms no my
position has shifted three times during
my campaign based on what I need to do
and be able to say the the life of the
mother I believe in limits Mark Kelly
doesn't and that's the choice that
arizonans face in this issue Mark Victor
please you know Ted disinvasiveness from
Blake Masters is exactly why you should
have a principle and stick with it you
asked them specifically did he scrub his
website and he said you can go to my
website now and look at it that's
evasion right that's an answer that yes
right anchored in principle I'm anchored
in principle my positions have been
exactly the same for 30 years look it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter what my
personal position is on abortion and I'm
not going to tell you we need a policy
that recognizes that reasonable Minds
disagree on this issue people disagree
there isn't and objectively right answer
and these politicians offer no special
wisdom at all this is why a one size
fits-all solution is a terrible idea
we're going to be fighting about it
forever Congress should stay out of it
so I'm in favor of having hard questions
like this resolved in the smallest
jurisdictions that's right Mesa should
pass a law that the people in Mesa I
know and the people in Tempe should pass
a law that the people in Tempe like
abortion should never anywhere under any
circumstances be outlawed in the case of
rape or in the case of health of the
mother we don't have time to get into
this but I've written extensively on
this in many other issues on my website
regarding abortions after viability if
we can keep the baby alive we should
it's a win for the baby it's a win for
the pregnant woman what if it has no
brain Aarons there is no perfect
solution in here we're going to be
fighting about it forever we need the
best solution to get past it and that's
put it in the smallest jurisdictions
here to stop fighting hey I don't even
think it should be decided by City the
each City councilor should be able to
have a different abortion law within
their little region of the city I think
there should be a national law that
protects the rights that women have to
make this decision between them and
their doctor let me be really clear
about something you asked about which
was the personhood Amendment now folks
this is code
this is code for throwing women into
jail
and that's what my opponent supports
now my I think we all know guys like
this
yeah you know guys that think they know
better than everyone about everything
yeah you know you think and guys who
think they're better because they're
tall
you even think you know better than
seniors about social security and you
think you know better than veterans
about how to win a war
folks we all know guys like this and we
can't be letting them make decisions
about us oh God because it's just
dangerous respond please I think States
should decide we let the state
legislatures wrestle with wrestle with
the tough question of how to regulate
abortion early on Texas is going to make
slightly different decisions than
California is going to make different
decisions than Arizona but I believe in
a federal backstop I don't think we
should let California or Oregon uh let
Planned Parenthood go in at eight months
and 30 days and sever spinal cords and
dismember babies
that his policy would allow unlimited
abortion up until the moment of birth he
still can't articulate a clear limit I
believe in limits Arizona has said 15
weeks is a reasonable place to draw the
limit and I agree I got to get a
response to that please yeah so I mean
the protections and restrictions that
were allowed under Roe v Wade was the
law of the land for over a century or
for 50 years but what we have now here
in the state of Arizona is a law from
1864. and it's exactly what my opponent
Blake Masters wants but have you
supported six seven eight month
viability I have supported Roe v Wade
you know went into effect in 1973 this
is a hard decision for women the answer
should be if my mind should be something
like listen when you say support you
want to make it sound like I'm going
around suggesting people have abortions
at nine months what I support is based
on my understanding that there are rare
but necessary situations for patients
and doctors to figure out without an
eight foot tall doofus getting in the
middle of that decision is making these
decisions for women all right I want to
get to um the election and Blake will
start with you is Joe Biden the
legitimately elected president of the
United States Joe Biden's absolutely the
president I mean my gosh have you seen
the gas prices lately legitimately I'm
not trying to trick you he's duly sworn
and certified he's the legitimate
president he's in the White House and
unfortunately for all of us right
because you know what yeah Joe Biden's
the president he has been for the last
two years and everything he's touched in
the last two years has turned
well to you know what everything's on
fire and it's Joe Biden's fault I wish
he weren't the president we're at full
employment that's a problem now how did
he get there okay let's talk about that
I think it's a problem
that the FBI forced Facebook they
pressured Facebook and other big tech
companies oh no to censor true
information about Hunter Biden's crimes
in the weeks before the 2020 election
and so millions of Americans didn't get
to read about that they didn't get to
read about Hunter Biden and his corrupt
business dealings with China and the
Ukraine business dealers which credibly
implicated Joe Biden and then the media
lied to us about it they said oh that
was Russian disinformation no it wasn't
it was true and so when the media is
lying to people helping big Tech and
apparently federal law enforcement
censor information about presidential
candidates well I think people start to
worry about the Integrity of their
elections and we need to do so much
better I believe in election day not
election season in Brazil does that
apply to Trump I think on Sunday guess
what they counted the votes and we got
to know who won that night and here's
another thing I believe that Mark Kelly
doesn't I believe in Universal voter ID
call me old-fashioned I think that if
you want to cast a vote in Arizona or
America you should have to show an ID
that's common sense and I'll stand up
for common sense election Integrity
every single I need to follow up quickly
was that election stolen was it rigged
in any way shape or form enough to keep
Donald Trump out of the White House I
suspect that if the FBI didn't work with
big Tech and big media to censor the
hunter Biden infra or the hunter Biden
Crime Story yeah I suspect that changed
a lot of people's votes I suspect
president Trump would be in the white
house today if big Tech and big media
and the FBI didn't work together now
understand that before this he has said
crazy things about the election yeah I
haven't seen evidence of that but I'm
telling you what I think the problem is
I think the problem is Big Tech big
media working together right okay well I
think that's a problem I challenge Mark
Kelly to say that's a problem we will in
just a second mark boy for a guy who's
never been elected before he sure sounds
like a politician to me I'll answer the
question Joe Biden won the election I
wish they both could have lost we could
use somebody up there who could have
done something different but look this
is an easy one all people of good faith
want a free Fair accurate open election
and we all want only people who are
authorized to vote to actually vote I
have no problems at all with reasonable
requirements to vote you should be able
to get an ID they're free if you can't
get an ID maybe you shouldn't be voting
that's not a big deal right what are the
documents you need to get the free ID
free and reasonably easily obtainable at
our harder for people who should be
allowed to vote to actually vote but all
of this is missing the big issue Ted
this is not our problem our big problem
with voting is that everything is up for
a vote today I don't want anybody
telling me how I should use my body my
property my money and my time none of
that should be up for a vote and I don't
want to tell any of you how to use your
body property money or time we are a
constitutional republic not an
unrestricted democracy today everything
is up for a vote very little should be
up for a vote like for example who
should represent the good people of the
State of Arizona that should be up for a
vote what should the age of consent be
this is something that reasonable Minds
disagree on that should be up for a vote
but everything else that we are voting
on that has anything to do with your
body what is that property your money
your time that's is what freedom is
about folks none of that should be up
for a vote Mark Kelly are there serious
concerns over Arizona's election process
over the country's election process that
were exposed in 2020. okay let me let me
start by saying the only reason
that we're having this conversation is
because my opponent Blake Masters put
out a video
questioning who won the president
presidential election here in the state
of Arizona
that election let's go back to 2020 that
was certified by Democrats and
Republicans you know I'm with our
governor on this Doug Ducey who says we
do elections well in Arizona and we do
80 percent of arizonans vote by mail my
opponent Blake Masters he just said he
wants to take that away from you
uh early in my Navy career I was in the
middle of the Indian Ocean and I was
able to vote in a presidential election
it's not a lot of countries you can do
that he wants to make that an
impossibility for our Arizona veterans
that's ridiculous do you know how many
do you know how many veterans you know
how many
people on active duty and Veterans wind
up getting deployed overseas and that
option would go away in his plan to just
vote on Election Day he mentioned voter
ID I'm okay with that you know these are
conspiracies and lies that have no place
in our democracy you know I'm worried
about what's going to happen here you
know this election in 2024 I mean we
could wind up in a situation where the
wheels come off of our democracy and
it's because of folks like Blake Masters
that are questioning the Integrity of an
election we do elections well in the
state of Arizona and you know folks it's
got to stop I encourage you to vote our
democracy is stronger when everybody
votes
my opponent wants to make that harder
for everybody are you trying to make
things harder for people to vote I want
to make it easy to vote and hard to
cheat I want Universal voter ID he
pretends to be okay with it he wouldn't
actually support it if he came to a vote
in the United States Senate look of
course I support absentee ballots for
military service members and it's
ridiculous and just a flat out
bald-faced lie to suggest that I don't
it's totally I'm just saying can we
please count the votes and know who won
on Election Day like a first world
country Brazil can do it so I think we
should demand no less in the United
States of America but you notice part of
the reason we quote can't is because of
the deadlines that are set by the states
and the rules and different systems that
each of the 50 states have I mean it's
it's not it's not a conspiracy corrupt
business dealings China Ukraine the
implicate they implicated Joe Biden but
that was all pushed under the rug
millions of people hundreds of thousands
of people in Arizona didn't get to hear
about that
I'm I I strongly suspect that that
changed the results of the election and
unfortunately for the whole country
because look how bad we're suffering
after two years of Joe Biden and Mark
Kelly was it a question more of
information not getting out or if
complaints that the election process
itself is quote rigged and allows for
cheating we we had multiple audits
of the election here in Arizona in 2020.
we had a partisan audit what did they
find it was accurate
you know I I find it interesting that my
my opponent Blake Masters is standing up
for veterans here for a second because
you know what I've heard during the last
you know year or so is just insulting to
Veterans you know it's kind of insulting
let me just say you know saying our
military is totally incompetent saying
there's rot in the military you know
saying things like
you know we haven't been in a just War
since before World War II
you know folks let me let me tell you
what he's talking about here he's saying
that World War II was unjust
you know we had hundreds of thousands of
Americans die in that war and I just
find it pretty insulting we've got about
500 000 veterans here in the state of
Arizona many of them you know vote by
mail we've got 80 percent of arizonans
vote by mail I imagine my opponent Blake
Masters has voted by males and now he
wants to take that away from us because
he's he he wants fewer people to vote I
mean that's the bottom line do you want
to take away vote by mail no
some people have good reasons to vote by
mail if you're on an aircraft carrier in
the Indian Ocean that sounds like a
pretty good reason for an absentee
ballot right about what about a a
Suburban housewife I'd be okay with that
if she enclosed a copy of her driver's
license I think that if you want to cast
a vote by mail you should at least
include a copy of your driver's license
didn't he earlier say everybody votes in
person on Election Day this has been
away this has been did you just say that
80 percent of arizonans vote by mail
this has been challenged in the courts
we have a stronger democracy when more
people vote a lot of people we had a lot
of people turn out in the last election
you know highest turnout ever in the
last election our governor Doug Ducey
says we do elections well these
elections were audited by and they were
certified by Democrats and Republicans
but conspiracy theories like the ones
that one he's peddling is dangerous to
our democracy folks I mean we're on the
verge of the wheels coming off of this
thing we've got to get back to a better
place
all right like you want to talk about
the military aspect yes there's a reason
57 of the veterans in Arizona are
supporting me right now 72 percent of
active duty military service members
right now in Arizona are supporting me
that's what my latest internal polling
says and there's a reason for that yeah
I speak out and I criticize General
Millie I criticize the top layer of
military leadership these very political
Obama did this right he purged the
military of so many great generals a
political General and he elevated in
their place left-wing mediocrities like
General Millie you've all seen at home
General Millie testifying in front of
Congress bloviating about white rage
talking about how we need to teach our
soldiers critical race theory in the
United States Navy right now they are
forcing Sailors to use gender pronouns
remember that what Millie said is we
should know what critical race theory is
projecting Force to defend America and
her allies are service members who wear
the cloth of the nation demand no less
they deserve no less and when I'm in the
Senate I'm going to work with Tom Cotton
to get rid of this wokeness yeah it's a
rot and so much of our military our
church deserve way better and when I'm
in charge they're going to get it uh
veteran talk to us here
I mean there's there's lots to talk
about here first of all to say that
because one General supported crazy
wokeness in the military and I certainly
agree with Blake this is not a place for
political correctness our military
exists to defend our country but because
one General said something ridiculous is
not an indictment of the entire general
uh officer Corps throughout our military
I've had many interactions with Marine
Corps officers and I can tell you very
squared away group I have nothing but
respect for the if you think their view
on pronouns is nuts wait till they tell
you about adverbs people who walked away
from Donald Trump in the exact same
policies that Blake Masters is now
promoting these were quality generals
and they had reasons to walk away from
the exact same policies okay uh
gentlemen we're running short on time
we've got the talk about water and I
wish we had more time to talk about this
but Senator Keller would start with you
uh 45 seconds let's start there and see
how far we go are facing short-term
long-term cuts of Colorado River water
how do we address this issue and it is
an issue it's a major issue I mean this
is the worst drought that this part of
the planet has seen in a thousand years
it's been going on 22 years Lake Powell
and Lake Mead are at crisis low levels
and we've got to take some immediate
steps I got money from Washington to
help farmers keep water up in Lake Mead
that's just a stop Gap measure we can't
do this all on our own we're one of
three lower Basin states with Nevada and
California I was on the phone recently
with the California governor because
they're not stepping up to help you know
my opponent's solution to this
he wants to privatize our water he wants
to send our water rights to Wall Street
he wants to send your Social Security
savings to Wall Street but our water too
and that's not that's not a serious we
are running approach this short on time
I need a response from you and a water
plan can you do it in a minute well I
think I can Senator Kelly recently gave
a news interview where he said don't
worry our water crisis in Arizona is not
existential well I disagree I'm here to
tell you that it is
I was shocked and dismayed a few weeks
ago when the federal government cut
Arizona's water allocation 592 000 acre
feet for all you water nerds out there
that's a lot of water that the feds cut
that's our water guess how much
California had to cut
zero guess what Mark Kelly did about it
nothing I'm tired of Senator Kelly
acting like the third senator from
California we need someone in there with
sharp elbows who's going to fight for
our water the late John McCain called
for the renegotiation of the 1922
Colorado River compact let's renegotiate
that I will but you know what we also
need technology and I can wrap this up
in 10 seconds why is California even
putting its straw into the Colorado
River that water should be Arizona's
look at a map California is on the
Pacific Ocean the future is desalination
plants powered by nuclear reactors and
pipeline okay we can solve this problem
with technology and sharp elbows I will
do it how do you talk about water and
not talk about the third element of the
bathroom elements of bathrooms okay I
got a few things it's got to be because
I've had very little time during this
debate and I'd like to give an answer on
this question but we're not going to be
able to get hurt if you keep go too long
let me incorporate some things that
Blake said Blake made some very good
points on this issue and I'm going to
give them credit we got short term and
long-term Solutions I'm here to tell you
about hard questions almost 80 percent
of our water in this state in the middle
of the desert goes to agriculture sorry
that doesn't make sense we can put our
agriculture we can get it from places
where they can more efficiently produce
these Goods the market price of water
should determine and that is Officer I'm
sorry but it's we just we just ran out
of time
and going in reverse order of our
opening remarks we start with Mark Kelly
yeah let me just say something uh what
my opponent said about being existential
it's not existential we're going to
solve this problem on water I think what
folks heard tonight here were starkly
different views of our state and our
country on abortion my opponent wants a
National Abortion ban taking away your
rights I'm going to protect abortion I'm
going to protect your constitutional
rights on Social Security he wants to
privatize it sending your savings to
Wall Street on issues of the military I
served in the United States Navy for 25
years I love our military he says some
pretty insulting things about our
military we have 500 000 veterans that
live in the state of Arizona
uh serving in the United States Senate
has been one of the highlights of my
professional life which has been all
about service and I would appreciate
your vote thank you sir
um uh now the closing statement from
Mark Victor thank you Ted Ted I'm
running for Senate to leave the world
better than I found it we've been on the
wrong course for a long time we have
very serious problems coming we're at a
critically important time in our history
both the Republicans and the Democrats
have given us a stalemate of ineptitude
they're recycling yesterday's ideas how
long are we going to accept their failed
approaches we can't solve these problems
with the same old thinking there is a
way out of this mess let's focus on
fundamental Timeless principles nobody
gets to force their way of life on
anyone else let's lead and inspire
people to be good humans time sir time
sir that is it still says I got 15
seconds there Ted I like to finish my my
close they told us that it was over
finally we hear from them told us it was
it was over
forever
forever
forever
forever
forever and Mark Kelly who
is over
everybody knows it you are less safe
today the Glock still had time on it
they cut him off Ellie took over
he's got a bunch of excuses I think you
heard a lot of them here tonight you
know it's up to you to decide whether
excuses are enough
but ask yourself do you deserve a secure
border
do you deserve to feel safe when you
walk outside at night do you deserve to
be able to afford your own home if you
work hard enough I think the answer is
yes you deserve so much better than what
we have Mark Kelly disagrees otherwise
he wouldn't have spent two years backing
Biden every time send me to the U.S
Senate if you think that you and your
family deserve better so we can go in
the right direction
thank you sir thank you gentlemen thank
you all for debate we appreciate it
what the hell they told us it was over
the clock still had time they cut them
off and then they go they told us it was
over what's over that guy's time it's
crazy what an insane I mean by the way
all of that being said
way better than the Beto Abbott debate
like at least 90 seconds and 45
follow-up instead of you know hey you
got seven seconds to give that was wild
that was really really wild overall
we're not learning like a ton from these
debates as you can probably uh
probably imagine all right I had one
other clip before the debate this is
from one of our favorite shows the Stu
Peters Channel thing I guess and I guess
the hurricane was
um some kind of globalist plot Florida
the governor Ron DeSantis has not been
complying with vaccine he's not been
complying with this climate change
agenda that the rest of the deep State
and Shadow government has been going
along with and pushing he's not been
complying with the sanctuary State
illegal immigrants Florida is booming
it's successful so many people have been
moving there and you know the economy
has boomed they didn't shut down during
covet oh oh my God and of course this
guy on the right I've interviewed this
guy on the right I'm gonna pull up my
old school okay let's watch this this
guy is nuts check this out right before
a major election too one month away it
just seems to me that oh what better way
to bring Florida to its knees this
booming economy this booming State let's
bring it to its knees with a hurricane
is it possible first of all for them to
do that and secondly I want to know what
makes this hurricane in your eyes what
are sort of the Hallmarks of a
manufactured hurricane yeah definitively
that store form hurricane Ian was
absolutely positively steered period we
recorded the animations of ground-based
radio frequency microwave Transmissions
I challenge your listeners to just look
at what we have captured all right I
can't even take it I I interviewed this
guy let's see when it was feels like it
was a decade ago
I interviewed this guy
uh no it was earlier than that
you know it wasn't 2017. let's see which
studio was this
oh I guess it was 2017. wait no it
wasn't uh yo here we go okay check this
out oh no it was like 2013. just check
out a little bit of this Okay let's
listen to it this is this is wild stuff
may not know what these are let's just
start there what are chemtrails
Chemtrails is a lady here we go
we want any firm David for geo
engineering which is climate Engineering
also known as solar radiation management
so in this case the science terms are
very important semantics are important
so the people find hard science data and
not uh conspiracy theory so this is an
attempt to modify the earth's climate
systems there's a number of stated
reasons for this again one is solar
radiation management that would be a
primary reason stated by numerous
patents we have about 150 patents on
these uh programs and we have Global
governance documents from Congress the
U.N and so forth so the primary stated
purpose David is to slow a runaway
greenhouse effect by filling the
atmosphere with light scattering
reflective particulates in this case
we're talking about heavy metals the
primary element is aluminum so these
programs are are quite uh damaging to
the human health now all of this has
been completely debunked organism in the
climate system as a whole so and how are
these how are these elements uh
dispersed I think that's a key question
aircraft disbursement yes this is this
is intentional payload disbursement from
aircraft obviously guys come on there
may be some method of disbursement by
mixing additives and fuel but we have
patents
film footage of spray disbursements with
material coming out of nozzles on
aircraft so this is a an intentional
effort to saturate the atmosphere with
reflective light scattering this is one
of the main Chemtrails guys uh Dr Steven
Novella writes about this guy in his
book particulates for the purpose of
solar radiation management and again
speaking in layman's terms when we see
often for people to kind of Link this
with what we see sometimes on the
Internet is are those images where we
sometimes see what seem to be streams of
either air or liquid coming from the
back of an airplane is that what we're
talking about here it is it is and
people have been led to believe that
anything you see in the sky is a
condensation Trail and quite simply the
science doesn't hold up in this case
people should be able to distinguish for
themselves when you see a grid pattern
one day and nothing the next obviously
there's something going on right and we
know from the type of jet engine on most
of these aircraft David a high bypass
turbo fan jet engine which we have a
tutorial in geogeneringwatch.org so
people can see how this engine functions
from for all practical purposes it's
incapable of putting out a condensation
Trail except under the most extreme
circumstances so we have film footage of
this happening at altitude people can
view these videos at geogenwatch.org or
other isn't this this gets completely
Bonkers besides so we we know that
they're spraying from aircraft so let's
go through a couple pieces first just
you mentioned that we want to separate
this from conspiracy theories and I
think it's interesting to use that term
because some people do consider this a
conspiracy theory so first just for to
provide some context for the audience
are there other so-called conspiracy
theories that you subscribe to in other
words words do you believe that the U.S
landed a man on the moon for example
you know I
should other areas
ding I'm not gonna I don't want to go
into those areas because I'm not
researching I have no opinion I I can
only state in this case we have film
footage of it happening so there's no
Theory involved we have about a hundred
lab tests in Northern California
hundreds from across the globe that show
that these metals are falling down on us
raining down no but Dan Dane I don't
want to interrupt but we're I want to
get to that but just to push back a
little bit on this and preparing for
this interview it seemed like on June
6th on the USA prepares radio show you
did say that you found it incredibly
unlikely that we landed anyone on the
moon and that we sent a buggy up there
here's what I said David I said this
here's where he starts to get irritated
with me that I think it's interesting
that we could leap up there in 1969 and
nobody's been back that's all I said and
that's all I will say and I do find that
interesting I think it's interesting
that nobody's ever been back but that's
all I said okay good good no I just want
to make sure that all the information I
have is accurate and that you did say
you did address that on that program and
you're saying that you did so let's get
now I want to get into some of the
specifics though of the chemistry it's
clear that that's all I said I mean I do
find that interesting and I stand by
that that's perfectly Fair yeah no we're
not going anywhere beyond that I want to
talk first there's just so much of this
you know and as a Layman it's hard to
wrap your mind around everything related
to Chemtrails I want to first talk a
little bit about the aluminum uh
specifically right the claims about
aluminum I did some research about this
and I went into it with with an open
mind and what I found was that there are
some error analyzes that have been done
uh for example one from Phoenix which
show levels of aluminum and barium that
are so high that if the tests were
accurate we would all be dead that was
kind of one set of studies that I found
I don't even remember the these parts
that this is this is this is pretty good
and then the other set of studies that I
found showed that while there were some
levels of these heavy metals in the air
that they were equal to or lower than
what we would would consider kind of the
normal levels that that are not uh in
any way a red flag and don't suggest
that any have been added so how would
you counter that data
well I can't speak for a test in Phoenix
that I didn't do but I can speak to Tess
in Northern California some of which
were done by U.S forest Service
biologists whom I work with and all of
these tests were done at the State
Certified lab there's a massive amount
of aluminum barium and strontium other
metals falling down in our rain now if
this was normal David it would not
affect aquatic insect life as it has in
Northern California in fact we've seen a
90 percent decline 90 of aquatic insect
life in Northern California 90
terrestrial insect life decline we've
seen aluminum escalate in the rain tests
from a baseline that was already high of
seven parts per billion to 3 450 parts
per billion in a single rain event this
is highly toxic rain there's nothing
normal about this and people have been
led to believe aluminum is abundant so
it's common to find it in the rain this
is absolutely ludicrous aluminum is
always bonded to other elements that
should not be in our rain unless you
live in a Sahara dust storm and uh quite
simply it wasn't there before the
aquatic insect life would have already
been dead now Dane as a as a scientist
if the uh and I asked this question not
rhetorically but because I want to learn
from you if these numbers are indeed
accurate from Northern California as you
stayed how is a scientist did you look
beyond the correlation of that data and
actually link Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
the reduction of aquatic insect life to
so-called aluminum that has been
released by airplanes in the air how did
you link those two things to go beyond
simply correlation and to causation
this is what we've always called for
David when we know this medal is falling
on us we know it wasn't there before we
know from California our resources board
it's not coming from China as a lot of
people would like to assume it's not
coming from China it's coming from
Planes you know that right and we know
it's in extremely toxic levels so much
so that it's changing force for pH is 10
to 12 times toward alkaline we know this
as well all right so that's kind of like
a gist of it let's go a little bit later
on where he really gets agitated with me
and just kind of like see where we're at
you can see the whole thing online if
you want you considered a traditional uh
commercial or trans transportative
airplane flight pattern that they could
be doing other things which in my
research again this is just my research
going into this with an open mind have
all been identified right sometimes
these so-called Chemtrails are uh hold
on a second hold on a second Dane hold
on just please let me let me get the
question out no no I don't think that
this you're trying to be objective here
when you're not when you refuse to use
the science terms I don't think that's
being tell me the term I should use and
I'll phrase my question I'm an engineer
in stratospheric aerosol geoengineering
solar radiation management stratospheric
Carousel injections but those terms
those terms imply proof of something
that I haven't seen proof of so let can
we find a term that would be more
neutral we can use for whatever climate
engineering that's what we're talking
about no but unfortunately let me use a
let me pick a term that I think is maybe
more neutral
um can I call them so-called at
Chemtrails would that be fair
uh you can't imagine you can't possibly
believe I would think that that's being
objective of course I don't this is this
is stratospheric aerosol Geo engineering
you have a mountain of science to back
it up and if you use the terms you're
using you come to conspiracy theory on
Wikipedia instead of hard science and it
seems that's the primary tool the
journalists use to try to discredit an
issue that has a mountain of science I
don't know about that I didn't use
Wikipedia at all for my research the
point I'm kind of going to is this in my
research Dan and again just let me get
the question out and I've provided you
certainly a time to respond here it
seems to me that all of these visual
phenomena let me call them that that
some in your field called stratospheric
geoengineering have been explained as a
combination of and I'll just State this
and then you'll have a chance to respond
fuel dumping
smoke generators to study wake vortices
tankers that release fired retardant for
fighting fires or training for fighting
fires some engines release exhaust some
airplanes have flares and then as you
mentioned there is the the maybe albeit
rare but existent condensation so what
proof do we have and when I say proof I
mean actual proof that this is aluminum
being deliberately released for climate
engineering purposes what proof do we
have
well first David when you say that we
should feel better about something being
a fuel dump as if that would make things
any better
um I don't find that so he's kind of
saying like hey you know what maybe it's
a fuel pump but that would be bad too
any better and that's a different
argument when we have film footage you
don't dump fire retardant at 30 000 feet
okay when you have when you have
military aircraft on film spraying from
nozzles and you have the same material
listed in those patents showing up on
the ground I challenge anybody to look
at the data when you when you talk about
your research I don't think that it's
really qualified as research and say you
observed a few Trails above the airports
near you we've done years of hard
research we have film footage of this
happening we have numerous lab tests we
have science documents we have in fact
let's go back to 1966 people all right
anyway you guys get the point he later
wrote an article about how unfair I was
to him which is actually very trumpy
even though it was years and years
before Trump all right everybody thank
you for joining me next debate is
someday next week we've got one or two
Trump rallies between now and then and
the new podcast tomorrow and the Pacman
Finance Channel and you know all these
different things so we'll see everybody
very soon